yeah so so I'm here to talk about data
science and regulated industries
obviously I'm going to focus on health
care but i think the things that i'm
talking about our relevant in banking
and in other places okay here we go yes
I jerk that I used to work with data you
give a little bit of my background I
started in consulting doing analysis for
like antitrust cases and the regulatory
side of big mergers then moved into tech
did things you hear about it a lot of
tech companies Facebook worked on ad
pricing and monetization stuff yambar
and then Microsoft after camera was
acquired I was working on like marketing
and sales and customer success related
projects but now i am CEO of this
company mode which i started with a
couple other folks about three years ago
so as you mentioned mode is a place
where analyst and data scientists do a
lot of their work it's a place to
actually create new analytical work but
also a place to share that with other
people in the company so the people who
use mode are like people like yourselves
who would attend a data science meet up
but also lots of other folks and that's
kind of like the first thing I'm going
to focus on in this talk is just like
some applications of how people are
using data science more broadly within
companies in regulated industries the
quick rundown on mode so the way that
people create new working mode is
primarily by writing some type of code
sequel or Python the reason that we do
that is because we are first and
foremost supporting analysts and data
scientists folks who are like answering
the hardest problems at their companies
and then we want to make it easy for
them to take that work and share it out
in a really sort of clean way with other
people in the company so a lot of the
folks who are using mode today are
creating analysis and then using that to
drive some kind of decision downstream
maybe not even in the analytics or data
science team but in some other team like
completely across that work chart in
their company there's a lot of companies
that use mode around here in particular
a lot of names you might recognize the
lifts and twitches kind of people who
are doing really forward-thinking stuff
that's actually different from what i'm
going to talk about today right so mode
is something that gets used in a bunch
of different industries the way that
people are using it in regulated
industries tends to be different because
of the different types of data that they
work with so you know what we hear about
a lot at meetups like this I think is
typically understanding user interaction
with a product other things related to
like consumer apps or software as a
service today it's a little bit
different so I want to tell stories
about a couple companies that are doing
interesting things that's really the
vantage point that I have now is I see a
lot of companies doing interesting
things with data and then I want to talk
a little bit about attitudes and and
compliance and regulation and how those
things all fit together so first company
I want to talk about is aspire health
it's a palliative care company so
they're not focused on the same typical
things like Tristan mentioned patient
outcomes that's actually not the number
one focus of data science at aspire what
they actually care about is operational
efficiency so they've got this team of
nurse practitioners and a number of
other folks doctors people who are
helping with client care helping
coordinate care so there might be like
five people who work with any one
individual patient and coordinating
across those five people is a data
challenge right it's about surfacing the
necessary information in order to
properly direct their time to the right
patients so what they've developed is a
bunch of internal tools so that they can
surface schedules right and information
about what's happening with each of
these patients so there's practitioners
can then do their job more effectively
they're using mode on the very end of
this like they're sort of solving the
meta problem they're bringing that back
and saying like hey how efficient are
these processes that we've created we
have these sort of internal data tools
let's feed that back in and understand
that at a deeper level like can we
create more efficiency among these teams
of people who are going out to care for
patients and as they start to scale
those efficiencies become more and more
important and in a lot of ways that's
like the business model right really
efficiently and effectively caring for
all of these patients
another one that I'm really excited
about is notable labs so heaven forbid
that any of you should be in this
position but let's say you have some
kind of uncurable cancer right or you
have cancer that's like not responding
to treatment you can send apply a biopsy
or some blood two notable labs they'll
test it against hundreds of different
drugs all fda-approved drugs and then
what will happen is maybe some
combination of drugs has off-label side
effects are going to positively affect
your specific cancer right so you can
see like exactly what is going to work
for you for the type of cancer that you
have that's complicated like I don't
actually fully understand it but the way
that they do the test is they have like
big plate and they test you know many
samples with lots of different drugs
right next to each other and I have to
do some complicated stuff to actually
account for which drugs and which
combinations of drugs are positioned
next to each other on the tray so
there's all kinds of really complicated
things happening on the back end right
similar to clover actually right there's
a lot of complicated stuff that
eventually works its way into like one
thing which is like a recommendation for
treatment right like the important thing
here is what drug or combinations of
drugs can a doctor prescribe to an end
patient that's going to help them have a
better outcome the way that they're
doing this is you know they're feeding
the results of this lab data into AWS
rights going into a database they're
putting it into mode and within mode
they're setting up reports so that they
have folks who are actually
administering care or like interacting
with patients those people can look up
an individual patient and see like the
effects of different drugs and which
ones are going to be the best and then
from there look at drugs and start to
understand like trends right so when
they see trends they can start to look
into like hey let's look at this drug
and interactions of all the other drugs
that we've tested it with across
multiple folks and then the next step is
sort of like let's predict new drug
combinations that are going to work for
a specific type of cancer where we've
seen like certain things work in the
past so the sort of trend among these
and actually I'll go I have one
or slide for clover like in any other
meetup I would talk about the
interesting stuff clovers doing but like
Justin did a way better job than I would
have I think there's a sort of there's a
sort of like common thread among all
three of these companies which is that
they are using data in a way that is
affecting individual decisions on like
an hour by hour if not more frequent
basis among people who are sort of in
the field doing something and the way
this works is actually like it's kind of
interesting because we think about
regulated industries as having these
super archaic systems and they do like
you might have to write COBOL but at the
same time there's this other force which
is like modern ways of doing things so
like clover is a modern company right I
think I I was like when I was practicing
this i was using both hands there's like
modern companies regulated companies
that suffer with these like archaic
tools i don't know how to do this with
the mic the modern companies right there
working in this open and transparent way
like if you look at these products
they're similar and similar to mode
right like we see ourselves in this
group as well of being places where
you're creating things and also
distributing them throughout your
company right it's a place not only
where like new stuff gets done but it's
a place where you can like bring someone
on board and they're going to be
productive because they're going to have
all of the work that was done in this
environment already right it's an
appealing way to work because it's fast
but if you're a regulated company you
might not have access to all of these
things like Dropbox for example when you
share a link in dropbox it's like on the
open Internet and then anyone can access
it which is really a big problem if that
contains health care information right
if you have pH I or like if you're
banking and that has like you know
someone's credit card information that's
like a no-go you're you're not using
Dropbox but there is this poll right
like if you think about regular
regulated entities there's a lot of
opportunity you just look at the amount
of money invested in health care in the
last couple years right there's tons of
opportunity there companies like clover
see it and they want to affect change
there in
or to do that they want to do it in a
modern way so like there's this pull of
like regulated companies towards modern
things and there's because it's so easy
to see the opportunity for companies
like clover like a company like mode or
like a number of the company's some of
the companies on this on this slide are
moving back the other way right they see
the opportunity as companies to help
folks in regulated industries and so
they are they are coming to meet them in
the middle to create tools and workflows
that are going to work for companies
like clover or aspire or notable labs so
when we think about like what the
problem is here there's two kinds of
complexity that make it tough one is
data complexity which is a problem that
many companies suffer the major
difference is that like for companies
and regulated environments you're not
necessarily going to have access to all
the tools to solve that problem right so
like your problem might look like other
folks but you're just kind of
handicapped from the beginning then
there's the regulatory complexity which
is to say like you need to be HIPAA
compliant or in other industries right
you have to follow legal guidelines
other compliance guidelines so I have
some thoughts about regulatory
complexity in particular and and as I
was putting this talk together I was
thinking you know like mode wasn't
always HIPAA compliant and at some point
we had to actually like make the
decision to become compliant and to meet
the sort of standards for serving
companies in regulated areas and when we
did that we realized I was actually not
as hard as we thought like people were
telling us it was going to be really
really bad and then when we got there we
were like oh this isn't too bad and I
think it has a lot to do with attitudes
and this is sort of like one of the main
one of the main things that I've learned
from this whole process in general is if
you have a certain attitude that is like
coming from this modern tool a little
bit back like if you're thinking back
the other way then a lot of this stuff
becomes really easy so I'll give you
examples so my first one this is this is
a little bit about how modes
architecture works so
on the far side of the slide you have
mode mode is a web app it's in the cloud
what's happening when you execute a
query in mode is we're sending that
query through a REST API to an agent
that lives in in your customers secure
environment so like for clover it's
affable in other cases it's like a VPC
and amazon something like that query
execute in the database locally and then
sends the data back to mode which we
then display in the browser this is
different from some other analytics
products where they just take all of
your data and cache it in the cloud the
problem with caching data in the cloud
is like if you're going to run advanced
queries on that data then it has to live
unencrypted which is like a little scary
to me generally but a total no-go in the
world of HIPAA right like that data's
got to be encrypted from end to end so
there's a whole category of products
that's just like out the door you can't
use them because they have fundamental
infrastructure problems that prevent
that we weren't thinking about that when
we first started the company we were
just thinking about like security and
doing the right things like what is the
thing that is most likely to leak data
for anyone regardless of whether you are
in health care or in finance or just
like the tech company down the street
another example that I think is maybe
more interesting is a thing in the
product and this is really like I think
this is what counts the most obviously
you have to like dot the i's and cross
the t's as far as like adhering to all
of the regulations that HIPAA puts forth
but there are things like sharing there
are a little bit more gray right so one
of the things you can do in mode is
after you complete some work you can
copy a URL and send it off to anyone at
your company I mean it's a URL dough so
you can send it to anyone technically
right but I mentioned Dropbox earlier if
that's a Dropbox link anyone can look at
it so I send it off to someone in the
company they don't realize that it's a
piece of sensitive information they set
it off to someone else like then you
maybe have a problem
right and worse you don't even know that
you have a problem because that link
can't be tracked we made this decision
in mode right from day one that in order
to see this link you've got to be in the
same company as the person who sent the
link and we're going to have verified
your email and you're going to be logged
into mode when you look at this link
right so so you have to go through a
series of checks in order to see this
thing and that's not necessary for HIPAA
compliance it's or not to make certain
things easier for us but I would say
like it's this attitude generally of
like thinking not just about our
infrastructure but about like let's make
sure that we're not going to like
accidentally goof or allow customers to
accidentally goof this part of what
makes mode useful and part of what
brings companies and regulated and
regulated environments over right it's
like let's be thinking about safety from
the very beginning we sacrifice
something in this right like we there
are customers who want to be able to
share things outside in fact like there
may even be people in this audience who
are like pissed at me who like want to
share stuff outside of their companies
and can't and we're okay with that
because we want to protect really
sensitive information so so to sort of
wrap there's there's kind of like two
things that I would say we're like the
main points here the first one is the
use of data in regulated companies is
not that different from the way it's
being used in non regulated industries
right at least from the perspective that
we see where it is about collaboration
in the sense of there's some kind of
team that's doing really advanced
analysis to drive the business forward
and it's about effectively getting that
out to other people in the business and
making them useful right making them
make better decisions in their job and
it's not really just about regulation
right like infrastructure and like
crossing all the T's and die in the eyes
that's super important but like you also
need to have a balanced approach that's
going to like consider risks in addition
to just like pure legislation
questions okay yeah it's not exactly
like guidelines and if you have to set
correct and you have to kind of
translate that and how it plays out your
business maybe you could just talk a
little more about how how you went
between the guidelines yeah so the
question the question is HIPAA is a set
of guidelines you actually self-certify
there's no like certification board that
says your HIPAA compliant so like how
did we interpret the rules and how do we
balance that it turns out to be pretty
annoying in fact like that that was the
hardest part of the process is
interpreting that because a lot of the
rules are meant for like doctors offices
so when you go and like try to
understand what HIPAA means it's like
well here's what you're supposed to do
with medical records that are lying
around in your office we don't have
medical records lying around in our
office and in fact like the only pH I
that's coming into mode is because like
customers of ours like clover are
writing queries and then that data is
coming into our system so part of it is
about interpreting this and I think
again it kind of goes back to attitude
of like okay well that's bias towards
being really safe and secure and like
think about things like okay well what
if you know what if clover like or
anyone for that matter like right to
query where there is like pH I in the
text of the query itself we have to be
able to deal with that in a way that's
like totally compliant which also means
like training all of the right people
and our staff unlike what PH I is what
you can I can't do with it we had to
come up with like a series of company
internal policies that are like hey if
you you know if you see some kind of
data you basically need to destroy it we
have a 10 page document that outlines
like what you're supposed to do as an
employee with basically anybody's data
like it actually applies to all of our
customer data but HIPAA was sort of the
thing that like really inspired us to go
deep on this
uh yeah I think that's I think there are
I think the other thing to consider so
there are there are services like cap
table that are like HIPAA compliance in
a box and we considered going that route
but it turn out to be really hard to to
get data flowing in and out like there
were a number of administrative problems
and I think like Amazon for what it's
worth is really good about HIPAA
compliance like they have standard bas
they have a series of like things that
you need to do in order to be considered
HIPAA compliant they take care of tons
of the sort of physical stuff like the
way that they maintain their data
centers it's like kind of already good
to go so like just a normal Amazon
infrastructure with like a few of the
right security checks in place was
enough there yeah in the back
yeah i mean the sharing decision is
certainly one that fits in into that
right but like the point of the our job
in a regulated industry is like don't
leak the data i happen to think not
leaking the data is like an existential
problem for us anyway like you know if
you use a data analysis product and we
like just kind of goof and and even if
like we give you the tools to leak the
data and you do it yourself that's
reflects really poorly on us and that's
part of why we bias in that direction is
because like it's just it's not it's not
worth it we definitely have people who
are who want to be able to share outside
of their own company walls and we'll do
that when we have a way to make it like
pretty secure yeah there's also like a
like a product right out there so you
know if we were to develop two separate
products one for regulated industries
and another one it's just like slows our
team down right that's like less that's
like fewer good core product
improvements that we're making and so
part of this also like let's not split
the team into and start working on these
two separate products like in the time
that it would take to do that why don't
we just like do it the regulated way and
then add a bunch of extra stuff that's
going to work for both audiences yeah
I'm so it's a how do we how do we
prevent
um I I guess so so the question is about
preventing vendor lock-in we're kind of
locked into amazon anyway I think like a
lot of our a lot of our customers are I
mean like Amazon seems like just sort of
a difficult choice for for probably most
of the companies that all of you work at
like if the companies were started after
2010 yeah I guess I just don't see it as
that much of a problem right now because
Amazon is like pretty cheap also like
it's it's the default product like red
shift for example is kind of like the
go-to for people outside of regulated
industries so it seems fine if you are
in a regulated industry
told I can take one more all right maybe
that's it thanks clover